[Música]
bienvenidos a primera plana de radio
francia internacional y france 24 esta
semana ponemos el foco en un pilar de
este país de la república francesa que
se viene poniendo en cuestionamiento la
igualdad de oportunidades o dicho en
forma de pregunta es la meritocracia un
mito nos acompañan en este estudio para
aportar elementos que ayuden a responder
a esta pregunta michelle vivió orca
sociólogo y autor del ensayo alarmes
imac con ego que vendría a ser entonces
señor macrón está usted contento
bienvenido michelle unos días de leer
una tec y periodista independiente
bienvenida gracias carlos florencia
valdés compañera de la redacción de
radio france internacional bienvenida a
florencia - 10 carlos el ascensor social
uno de los pilares de francia ha puesto
en entredicho hoy en primera plana
es la meritocracia un mito esa es la
pregunta base sobre la que vamos a
reflexionar y existen argumentos en los
dos sentidos aquí en francia un reciente
estudio del instituto de estadística
dice que el 70 por ciento de los hijos
de los hijos con padres modestos han
ascendido en la escala de ingresos dice
el informe que sí que las condiciones
socioeconómicas de los padres influye en
las que tendrán los hijos pero no son
decisivas porque efectivamente existe un
ascensor social un elemento que ha sido
sin embargo puesto en entredicho en los
últimos tiempos por la desigualdad
social la meritocracia tiene un origen
progresista pues echaba al suelo el
sistema aristocrático que ha dominado la
mayor parte de la historia de la
humanidad es en el que los privilegios
se heredan de generación en generación
la cuestión es si funciona o bien si se
va a ser mitos repasemos algunas
portadas libération usted es rico en una
llamativa portada con el papel higiénico
color oro dice el rotativo que el
observatorio de desigualdad propone
fijar una cifra de ganancias a partir de
la cual uno es rico tal y como pasa con
la pobreza y la estima en tres mil
setecientos euros netos al mes un 7% de
los franceses la sobrepasan télérama
título a un artículo dedicado al tema
que hoy abordamos meritocracia la
francesa un mito sin mérito haciendo una
especie de juego de palabras la net 2
dedica este número a resolver la
pregunta cómo vencer las desigualdades y
este otro artículo del diario económico
les echos pone el acento en una
percepción muy extendida en francia de
la que hoy vamos a hablar porque los
franceses no creen en la meritocracia
bueno michelle llegar arriba social y
económicamente a través de los méritos
propios es hoy en general un mito
podemos utilizar esa palabra o no bueno
el mito no funciona hoy día eso es el
tema el sic si tú pregunta a los
franceses de manera muy general cómo van
a vivir sus hijos todos casi todos te
van decía menos bien que yo bendecía el
no funciona no funciona el tema entonces
él no es un mito es un anti mito si
puedo decir así que dice no funciona mal
y la verdad hay un trabajo de la sede la
organización estadística francesa que
demuestra qué
funciona no perfectamente que hay muchos
muchos problemas pero bueno ahora hay
que ver que hay lugares donde no
funciona realmente por ejemplo en el el
sistema francés es académico tiene las
rondas de cola como el lugar para el
éxito fall social en los años
40 o 50 o 60 hay un cierto nombre de
hijos de obreros que pueden ser
parte de este sistema hoy ya no hay más
no hay más ella
es un lugar donde no funciona el ascenso
social pero hoy hay lugares donde
funciona muy bien en los mass-media por
ejemplo en las en el comercio en aix hay
lugares donde funciona lugares donde no
funciona y para ser un poco más preciso
el tema tienes varias dimensiones hay
una dimensión social realmente social mi
papá es obrero yo no quiero ser obrero
pero yo vos 6 yo voy a ser maestro de
escuela 9 ese es social de otro lado y
eso es muy francés es el tema de la
república y del estado hay la idea que
la república el estado va a ayudar
ayudar a los jóvenes al éxito social y
eso no funciona mal porque la república
francesa como tal tiene una crisis que
las instituciones no funcionan entonces
es diferente si tú eres hijo de obrero
a la escuela pública y que el maestro
muy bien te voy a apoyar te voy a
hacer de tal manera que tú tienes una
beca que tú puedes acceder a la escuela
normal para ser maestro bueno es no es
social es el estado que te apoyas que
esté a esta dimensión y hay una tercera
dimensión después me acabo vos el
llevarlo demasiado pero la tercera
dimensión es que la sociedad ha cambiado
tan mucho que es muy difícil de hablar
de ascensión social hoy ya en este país
cuando la gente no siempre piensas en
términos clásicos de clase social de
clase esos por ejemplo yo acabo con esto
por ejemplo hoy ya el importante para
mucha gente no es de ganar más el
importante desde vivir de manera
diferente de de salir de la ciudad para
ir líder en el campo y trabajar recto a
distancia el que quiere por ejemplo
respirar aire aire puro como aspiración
en la vida poco le importa que las
clases sociales que tenga a su alrededor
sean más pudientes o menos entiendo que
van por ahí los tiros aspiraciones
clases sociales valores republicanos
varios conceptos que nos ha puesto mi
servicio arcas sobre la mesa es un mito
la meritocracia del yang no yo no creo
que sea un hito porque hay muchas
personas que logran lo logran así que
confirma que no existe lo que pienso
yendo por el mismo camino es este que ha
habido un cambio de paradigmas
lo que antes era concebido como una
movilidad social por ejemplo pasar el
back caloría el examen del examen
secundario de acá en francia o mismo ir
a la universidad ya no es considerado
como una excepción ya que la mayoría de
jóvenes lo obtienen van a la universidad
mismos ceden a una maestría pero ellos
ya nos lees ya no resulta podemos
encontrar un trabajo un buen trabajo y
mismo cuando se encuentra el trabajo eso
tampoco asegura que una estabilidad
económica ni siquiera que se pueda hacer
carrera en la misma empresa entonces los
paradigmas han cambiado y si se ve a
través de de ese ángulo definitivamente
el mito ha perdido mucho valor
florencia no es un mito porque
efectivamente como dice michel y como
dice de ella hay cosas que sí funcionan
y que todavía aunque haya crisis
institucional es un estado que funciona
las escuelas mucha crisis en las
escuelas son escuelas que funcionan
también lo que pasa también que es las
aspiraciones han cambiado y por ejemplo
los papás de las personas que tienen 30
40 años hoy tenían un esquema de vida
bastante definido era tener un empleo a
partir de los 20 años y trabajar hasta
la jubilación el mismo empleo en la
misma empresa subiendo la escala social
en esa misma empresa tener la casa tener
el auto vacaciones a la playa en el
verano vacaciones a la montaña en el
invierno y todo eso como dice él es un
cambio de paradigma en todo este
ascensor o digamos el camino de la
ascensión social ha cambiado y las
aspiraciones ya no son las mismas si
desde luego no fuera un mito como
en mis compañeros de la mesa lo que sí
que hay lo que sí es que está extendida
que en francia es la percepción social
de que no funciona en la extensión
social aquí atribuyen a que esa
percepción esté tan extendida
socialmente como social algo michelle
bueno los franceses viven eso sí de
acuerdo nosotros un cambio de paradigma
la sociedad es totalmente diferente no
estamos más en los años 50 y 60 los
pilotos franceses llaman las 30 glorias
hace ese período de 30 años el
crecimiento económico entre el 45 y el
75 lo aclaró por si alguien que no eso
se acabó en este un momento de cambio
muchas cosas se transforman incluyendo
las instituciones el sistema de la
educación tienes muchas dificultades hoy
ya cogemos los franceses antes piensan
que el sistema francés era el mejor del
mundo bien en las encuestas
internacionales que dicen no están mal
pero no es también bueno el sistema de
salud tiene muchas dificultades
y la justicia
todas las instituciones francesas
funcionan con muchas dificultades
entonces eso es un primer punto el
segundo punto es que a una dimensión
territorial muy importante y la ingesta
del lince le demuestra como es decir si
tú vives en el campo lejos de la ciudad
y que tú eres de una familia pobre va
sea mucho más difícil de subir que si tú
vives en el cerca de parís en un barrio
popular o cerca de parís y en una
familia pobre pero hay más oportunidades
en el lugar donde vives es importante es
un tema bueno y el tercero punto es la
relación de los franceses al trabajo la
sanción social es conectar akrón
trabajar trabajar y trabajar en trabajo
que me gusta que me interesa en la misma
empresa por ejemplo antes la y yo empezó
en la empresa y en la misma empresa yo
sé ya la gente saben que van a cambiar
314 veces en su vida de empresa con
momentos de no
todo cambia
perdón probablemente esta noción de
trabajar era realmente no había menos
digamos había esta idea de placer en el
trabajo y de cumplir con realizaciones
no era trabajar porque además tengo
suerte de trabajar porque hay que comer
y eso también ha cambiado perdón y les
quería preguntar puestos tan en tela de
juicio aunque no sea un mito el concepto
de meritocracia les pregunto por el
mérito existe una tiranía del mérito es
decir algo que socialmente está
considerado como bueno per se y no se
entiende que no se persiga y sin embargo
en la base es como estamos viendo hay
falacias de algún tipo hay una tiranía
en ese en esa persecución del mérito del
ya si yo pienso que sí sobre todo la
forma en la que es percibido actualmente
ya que el mérito por ejemplo para los
niños y los jóvenes es tener buenas
notas es decir el que mejor notas tiene
va a lograr los mejores puestos pero lo
importante acá no solamente es el mérito
de las notas sino también tener en
cuenta el mérito personal individual es
decir si los niños o los jóvenes vienen
de un contexto social de favorecido si
no han tenido el apoyo de los dos padres
solamente ha tenido han tenido un
monoparental si es
hay que tener en cuenta el mérito pero
también para que sea realmente justo el
mérito individual contextualizando lo
que en este momento no ocurre les
propongo hacer un pequeño comentario de
texto ojo a la frase aquellos que han
llegado a la cima creen que su éxito es
obra suya evidencia de su mérito
superior y que los que quedan atrás
merecen igualmente su destino dice el
filósofo de la universidad de harvard
misses and el premio princesa de
asturias de ciencias sociales 2018 y
autor del libro la tiranía del mérito
están de acuerdo con ello
hoy ya isaac hablando ahora de francia y
de estados unidos en américa eso de que
yo he llegado aquí y me lo merezca y el
que se ha quedado ahí se merece lo que
siguientes antes el discurso era muy
diferente antes y dice el sistema es mal
el sistema es capitalista el sistema es
la dominación de ciertos y entre sí no
puede ser en la movilidad ascendente es
porque el sistema no es bien hoy ya la
gente
y mucho más gente si yo no soy el nivel
que yo quiero es porque yo no soy bueno
es son mi calidades personales en los
pies o introducir una manera muy
diferente de vigueras y hay un segundo
punto que es que la gente que tiene el
éxito al más alto nivel hoy en francia
tiene una imagen muy negativa son
tecnócratas son productivas son gente no
es no se puede creer lo que dicen dónde
lo francesc critican todas las élites
entonces cito crítica las élites eso
significa que la imagen de la ascensión
social puede ser un poco negativa lo que
son en la ascensión no son los buenos
son los
que haga una breve pausa y enseguida
volvemos hablando de la meritocracia
quien en primera plana hasta ahora
por qué de bienvenidos a la noticia de
france
telecom
bien por la media decisión explicó
[Música]
arias y café
según wagner casi 99 millones de ustedes
nos siguen cada semana en france 24 su
chrome taxis o conference minsk 1 chivas
muchas gracias sus grandes dirigentes
con sólo 20 meses y de formosa
liberté égalité actual y t
enlace del conosur a norteamérica de los
andes' a centroamérica una cita semanal
con los temas más importantes de los
países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de la meritocracia es la
meritocracia un mito al menos es uno de
los pilares en los que se fundamenta la
república francesa y está siendo
cuestionada mucho últimamente lo hacemos
con el sociólogo michelle vivió acá y
las periodistas de él ya runa tegui y
florencia valdés en delhi a los medios
de comunicación y las librerías están
llenos de ejemplos moralizantes de
superación personal y de manuales
destinados a la ascensión en la cima
cómo influyen socialmente estos ejemplos
de superman y la superwoman el manual de
cómo ser un superman o una superwoman
sobre todo una superwoman últimamente sí
bueno yo creo que pueden influir de dos
formas como una especie de motivación
para llegar a esa excelencia que ahora
es el paradigma tanto a los medios
sociales en las empresas mismos se ven
linkedin por ejemplo los posteos de
personas que logran
enormes cosas y sobre todo la
individualización es decir en lograrlo
lograr algo por sí mismos pueden
empoderar pero también puede tirar para
abajo las personas que no se reconocen
en ese tipo perfiles tan particulares
porque se dicen yo no tengo este perfil
nunca voy a lograrlo porque estos estas
personas perecen pertenecen a una casta
entonces están los dos las dos
posibilidades eso también es un mito
porque aunque una persona que venga de
un medio muy humilde y que hayan logrado
salir de ese medio para hacer otras
cosas si su tía vendió sopa el domingo
para financiar el transporte si en su
casa le pusieron más luz para que
pudiera hacer las tareas todo eso son
cosas pequeñitas son pero es una red de
apoyo que existe entonces nadie se hace
solo por mod y ese mito claro el orégano
de los años 80 este statement que viene
de eeuu que sale de cualquier lado y que
a pulso y quedándole y way se vuelve a
rockefeller pero es ese es el mito
ese es el mito una idealización
la idea de meritocracia se utiliza para
que un sistema social profundamente
desigual parezca justo cuando no lo es
se utiliza como end como herramienta por
el sistema la meritocracia bueno es
parte es parte del funcionamiento por
ejemplo la francia durante el siglo 19 y
el siguiente la francia dice de américo
de grazia es posible es posible porque
el estado te va a apoyar a ayudar y no
únicamente tus cualidades personales es
decir es parte del tema pero lo que me
llama la atención hoy ya es que se va
usted habla de todos estos libros
artículos no ha hablado de libros que
son muy numerosos sobre el desarrollo
personal y eso es muy importante el late
lady es que no es que el mérito es tan
importante lo que es importante que si
yo soy capaz de desarrollar mi
personalidad como director que es muy
diferente del de antes y por eso me
parece que hay que tomar en cuenta el
cambio cultural en este país el
individualismo qué significa hay gentes
que quieren ser deportivas importantes
eso no es móvil nuestra ascenso social
pero si tú hablas con gente con jóvenes
quieren ser ser como
personalidades de los media de la tele o
del cine
exactamente y entonces es eso hace que
la idea que yo voy a trabajar yo voy a
subir de manera progresiva eso daré para
ciertos y eso funciona para es cierto
pero para otros es totalmente otra cosa
mucho más importante decir y es una
palabra que faltaba que hay que decir yo
no puedo subir como quiero porque hay
discriminación es el tema de la
discriminación es parte del problema
entonces están muchas cosas en el tema
de la de la meritocracia que es un tema
muy complejo y no hay una uan vez ue no
hay un único modelo de habla de eso
vamos a proyectar en las políticas
públicas
que se puede exigir a un gobierno por
ejemplo al gobierno francés al
presidente de macrón para que mejore o
se re dinamice la cuestión del ascensor
social que podemos exigir a las
administraciones públicas delia darle
más opciones a las familias
desfavorecidas yo creo que el gobierno
está poniendo ciertas está implementando
sientas ciertas medidas para que el
bache que existe entre los jóvenes y
niños de familias desfavorecidas y los
que pertenecen a una élite no sea tan
grande por ejemplo en el aspecto
cultural a través del pase cultural que
existe que es a partir de los jóvenes a
partir de 15 a 18 años el gobierno les
da una especie de crédito entre 30 entre
20 30 euros y cuando cumplen 18 300
euros para que utilicen ese dinero para
bienes culturales puede ser para ir a
museos conciertos de cualquier
preferencia teatro en fin yo creo que es
una inversión importante hacia el futuro
para que estos chicos jóvenes también
disfruten de las cosas que los otros de
familias favoritas
es importante también por ejemplo de la
agencia de trabajo público están
incentivando a la gente que está
buscando empleo con formación es sobre
todo en el mundo digital eso también
puede
dinamizar el ambiente familiar y bueno
ponernos a estudiar también a los
jóvenes ya los no tan jóvenes creo que
es muy bueno florencia que otras porque
creo que poner la atención también de
las de las fracturas geográficas
michelle lo mencionado error o realidad
hablar porque se ha intentado porque
bueno sabemos que es un país muy
centralizado muy jacobino pero ese hilo
y creo que lo decías tú también es muy
importante la diferencia entre la
francia rural y la francia urbana y es
lo que decíamos es un chico de familia
inmigrante en isla de francia aquí en la
región parisina va a tener más
oportunidades que un chico que viene de
una de una zona rural entonces ponerle
atención a eso porque inclusive el
acceso a la educación
pasar solo del colegio al liceo que es
la etapa antes de los estudios
universitarios es muy difícil porque
tienen que viajar kilómetros tienen que
ir a un internado el internado es caro
entonces la territoriales más que
inclusive a veces que los orígenes
michelle la escuela pública en cualquier
caso sigue siendo el principal elemento
de este ascensor y no sé si podríamos
decir que según sea la calidad de esa
escuela pública es el ascensor estará
más o menos engrasado estoy totalmente
de acuerdo el tema de la educación
primaria secundaria y universitaria
también son temas absolutamente
decisivos hoy día este no funciona bien
y cuando el sistema de educativa no
funciona como pienso que debe funcionar
lo que pasa en y es el caso de
influencia es que no hay imagen positiva
del futuro y es el porvenir
en los años 50 y 60 tú eres obrero y tú
qué piensas tal vez eres comunista o
socialista como si obtienen un sindicato
o qué sé yo y tú tú sabes que la vida es
dura para ti hoy pero que mañana va a
ser mejor para aquí y va sea mejor para
tus hijos hoy ya nunca se habla del
futuro de esta manera entonces yo pienso
que necesitamos en un país como francia
un sistema educativo que permite a los
jóvenes de imaginar un futuro mejor y no
únicamente de saber que un día hay que
trabajar y engañar su vida entonces eso
falta mucho en este país no hay no hay
imagen posible de un futuro realmente
mejor para todo el individualismo y
entonces la educación debe tomar eso en
cuenta lo que significa
no únicamente
hablar de matemáticas o de franceses
pero hablar de cómo ser sujeto de su
experiencia de su existencia para
construir un otro mundo donde yo vivo un
mejor un tema polémico sin florencia
bien darán la oportunidad a los
profesores de trabajar en condiciones
adecuadas porque es lo que vemos este
verano hay una crisis muy muy grave para
atraer a los profesores desde la escuela
desde la escuela materna hasta el liceo
hasta las universidad entonces también
para que los niños aprendan y tienen que
tener gente enfrente que quiere
enseñarles
un tema muy polémico del que yo he leído
todo tipo de teorías las nuevas
tecnologías que la tocó tangencialmente
delia antes juegan a favor o en contra
del ascensor social en este tipo de
porque
las más tecnologías como lo ve del ya
depende también de la forma que se sean
dirigidas porque es lo que más impacta
en nuestra sociedad y vemos que una
democratización en el acceso a la
cultura como hablaba pero también puede
ser un obstáculo en el acceso entonces
donde nos posicionamos a ver la forma en
la cual son dirigidas por ejemplo como
mencioné en linkedin cuando cuando uno
las personas en general vemos perfiles
super inflados de gente con mucho éxito
con una hoja de vida impresionante puede
generar el efecto opuesto es decir no
sentir una motivación sino sentirse que
quizás no se llegan a las alas
cualidades que ahora son apreciadas
ahora la
competitividad es este se ha vuelto la
regla del juego no solamente en el
ámbito académico sino también en el
trabajo quién es más combativo quién es
el más ambicioso la ambición se ha
vuelto una característica positiva ante
la ambición era visto como algo negativo
yo creo que eso se ve a través de las
redes sociales sobre todo quién logra
más quién es mejor y a veces es un poco
es un juego un poco
caníbal transforma también el objetivo
porque si los chicos lo que están viendo
en las redes sociales están hay muchos
vídeos de eso de gente que exhibe sus
bolsos de lujo sus zapatos de lujo su
tren de vida súper lujoso cuál es el
objetivo para ellos ese es el objetivo
relacional y hablamos antes
aspiracionales en el centro de entonces
el mérito se convierte en está como nube
un poco intangible de a yo lo que quiero
es eso pero como vaya a esta persona que
tal vez no tiene la posibilidad a
comprarse esa bolsa a subirse ese yate y
eso se vuelve el objetivo y no bueno
pues está los voy a ir a la universidad
voy a estudiar esto y voy a trabajar de
esta manera esto eso transforma también
el objetivo es el bueno como todas cosas
que son técnicas o tecnologías hay dos
caras una cara positiva y una cara
negativa y además yo soy de acuerdo con
usted hay una medición otro vocabulario
alguna fractura numérica claro en el s&p
entonces mira el confinamiento para los
jóvenes que eran en su casa de un lado
de un lado la utilización de internet
fue muy útil cuando tú no puedes ir a la
escuela pero viene un momento donde es
muy claro que para ciertos es muy útil
pero que para otros no funcionan me
quedo sin tiempo muchísimas gracias a
los tres ha sido un placer estar con
ustedes hablando de la meritocracia
hemos puesto muchísimos elementos sobre
la mesa sólo agradezco d elía florencia
michelle y a todos ustedes esperamos a
que en primera plana la próxima semana
muchas gracias